c'était terrible parce qu'on lui
reprochait son corps c'est à dire ce
qu'elle est on lui reprochait d'être une
gymnaste sur des patins et pas une
patineuse c'était hyper violent et quoi
qu'elle fasse il y avait la mafia des
justes qui la mettait 2e 3e jamais
première parce qu'elle était noire et
parce qu'elle était sûre yabeun annick
pour vous avez répondu oui à la question
oui pour moi la france est raciste un
bain je réponds avec mon coeur 1,1
million d'actes racistes en 2019 c'est
énorme si les + 40 % c'était donc oui la
france est raciste on n'a pas réussi à
éradiquer cette monstruosité les
mentalités changent et l'éducation des
enfants chantent je vois ma fille de 6
ans c'est à dire qu'on nomme pas les
gens avec tel on nomme par le prénom
c'est à dire que pas pour une part une
apparence par une grandeur une taille
une couleur mais je crois que c'est
aussi ça une éducation iv vigneault la
parole est libérée et métaux les gens le
disent vraiment je suis raciste il faut
admettre que n'y en a
que
sur 1,7 me dit il ya un racisme en
france et derrière il ne disait pas son
nom il est plein qui soit claudie
vraiment mais mes firme est ce que je
trouve très dur en ce documentaire comme
c'est par exemple dans le cas de surya
bonaly je me sois très bien que lui
reprochait de ne pas être très gracieux
dans la danse à aucun moment fakih qui a
dit à un moment que ses dessins couleurs
honduras yeuse parce que sous-entendu
son corps était tout noir n'était pas
tant sur sa vie vous n'avez jamais
entendu ça parce que dans l'imaginaire
rassure me disais voilà exactement mais
dans la nature de sa femme à disposer de
l'assise même quand on subit subtilement
les choses comme ça c'est du racisme qui
ne disait pas son nom mais maintenant
les gens luttent oui mais pas les juges
c'est ça qui m'a permis aux dogues c'est
qu' aucun juge ne dit après coup je
reconnais qu'elle aurait dû gagner donc
c'est un racisme peut être aussi à
l'envers de dire est ce qu'on n'est pas
en train de dire que c'est un racisme
alors qu'elle était juste à ce que de
mériter le moment j'attends c'est bien
du racisme mais je ne peux pas dire
jamais je ne pourrais dire que ce pays
est raciste ou qu'il aidera six jours
accueillera saint denis un racisme au
foie ou ça voilà on y est a dit bien sûr
mais la france et des personnes suivent
marine le pen en autriche signé oui bon
d'accord c'est que tous les gens qui
suivent marine le pen sont racistes il y
en a beaucoup qui le disent oui mais
c'est pas que j'en accepte les thèses de
marine le pen oui mais sont pas tous
racistes firme hennessey
alors on va voir on a besoin des
problèmes dénoncés par les personnes qui
témoignent dans le documentaire aussi
alors ça ça a dérangé c'est aussi le
rapport avec la police et plus
précisément toutes les fois ils seront
arrêtés regardez le témoignage de
soprano
appel avec mon groupe les psy4 de la
rime en prend le train pour aller en
concert et que on est en première classe
et qu on connait tous tranquilles et que
tu vois le contrôleur qui arrive n'a
même pas commencé qu idy la deuxième
classe et là bas et qui voit que notre
manager et blanc et qui nous dit il
parle français eux toi tu es là tu le
regardes tu le penses que tu poses des
questions que tu ne vois qu'il devient
tout rouge que la police a été appelée
avant même de contrôler tous nos papiers
mon truc tout simplement parce qu'il
nous a vus et par contre ils ne
parlaient pas avec nous nous parler
qu'avec notre manager blanc la police
qui nous attend qu'on descend alors
qu'on a vu nos billets comporter faire
des concerts dans ma tête je sais qu'il
a ouais quand même quand même c'est
parti jusque là on n'a même pas dit un
mot c'est parti trop loin mais notre
sopra que j'embrasse d'ailleurs qui est
formidable oui moi j'ai trouvé le
documentaire absolument incroyable très
édifiant mais en même temps je suis un
peu d'accord avec mathieu c'est à dire
que je pense que la france n'est pas
raciste par essence enfin moi je me
méfie quand on essentialiser quand on
globalise alors oui à des racistes oui à
la discrimination oui à du contrôle au
faciès oui la violence policière parce
que vous êtes noir ou parce que vous
êtes haram et donc c'est insupportable
il faut la combattre il faut pas
essentialiser il faut pas globaliser non
sinon s'en sortira pas